all right
all right here we go
so i already introduced myself but the
last thing my twitter handles camille
please feel free to
tweet me with any comments or feedback
or questions if you have them after the
talk i'm always happy to answer if
you're not comfortable raising your hand
right now and ask me anything
all right so you're here because you are
interested in storm a member of the
storm community maybe a member of the
hadoop community here in new york uh
interested in big data probably you are
dealing with it thinking about it
worried about it um and
there are a number of you know big data
is the hot thing right now we've got
strata hadoop world coming into town
next week uh you know that conference
has grown and grown and grown
humongously over the last few years
and in part of the reason that big data
has become such a
big buzzword topic is because we've
started to really have this blossoming
of open source systems out there that
are built to handle big data and make it
easy for people to process it without
having google's budget to actually you
know create internal software to do so
and these systems are kind of pretty
varied all right you see you've got
hadoop
um you've got apache solar which was
originally built to be sort of a single
you know single point um that's been
turned into apache solar cloud where you
can run multiple servers to do your
indexing
storm which doesn't really have an icon
but this is the best i could do
which all of you hopefully are fairly
familiar with and we've got kafka which
also doesn't have an icon
and so you know these systems and many
others are big big systems big data
systems they were designed to be able to
process
many gigs many terabytes of data
in some manner batch real time what have
you
and in order to handle that volume of
data in a reasonable time period you
know not taking weeks and weeks and
weeks to give you a result these systems
uh by you know basically had to become
gigantic big distributed systems so
they're processing this big data you've
got these giant distributed systems and
you end up with a number of challenges
that all these systems face because
they're dealing with because you know by
their nature they have to be these big
distributed systems so one of the
challenges you've got challenges of
outages i'm sure everyone in this office
if you're running you know if you're
running storm in production or any kind
of a system in production you're
familiar with thinking about outages
right what happens when a node goes down
when a network partition it's just what
it just corrupts you know what happens
right what happens when you have
something go wrong when you're building
a big distributed system especially the
architects of those systems they have to
think about outages
at the beginning right you cannot build
a system where it's not available if a
single node goes away it's just nobody's
going to use that right would you ever
run a system with 50 nodes in production
and every single node has to be
available for your system to work so
outages are a first-class citizen of
concern for any architect working in a
distributed system
coordination is another big challenge
that you have to be dealing with right
who's doing what's task uh how do i know
you know that everyone has finished task
a and move on to task b all those kinds
of issues right coordination is a big
challenge when you're dealing with task
based systems that many of these systems
are
and then there's just the simple issue
of operational complexity when you're
talking about running tens or hundreds
of nodes of a system you do not want to
force your admins to have to go in and
ssh into every single one of those
systems and change files and configure
things and twitter mobs to bring your
code up and running you don't even want
them to have to run a chef script to do
that you really do not want to have to
have humans touching every single node
all the time to configure things and to
change things and so you want to really
reduce the operational complexity as
much as possible
most systems also have a fairly common
deficiency which is that most of these
big distributed systems don't have great
consistency guarantees okay maybe
they're eventually consistent whatever
eventual means but depending on the
failure modes and depending on the modes
of operation it's hard to know when
you're going to get the final answer to
a piece of data question right is this
data actually in its final state is it
still changing how do i know even in a
database right this is actually not
non-trivial thing to do how do you know
that someone hasn't
written
a piece of data to this table that you
are going to try to write to just throw
in this table you have to put in
timestamps and be checking put a bunch
of transactions all over the place it's
non-trivial even in a database and most
of these nosql systems don't even really
try to give you a huge amount of
consistency guarantees and ordering
guarantees so
these systems all have very common
challenges and they pretty much all have
this common efficiency
and so
this is where zookeeper comes into play
because zookeeper
has the ability to help with all of
these problems um and it has the ability
because it has very strong consistency
guarantees and strong ordering
guarantees
so quickly what does zookeeper use for
in storm it's used for coordinating the
cluster so
one of the basic things i just listed
there right coordination huge issue
that's what zookeeper is doing in storm
it's not used for message passing it's
not used as a gigantic cache it's not
used for any big complex thing it's just
simply used for configuring investors
coordinating the cluster i should say um
and so
where what is zookeeper and why why is
it the system that all of these
different projects are using for solving
these problems
so zookeeper centralized service for
maintaining configuration information
naming providing
distributed synchronization and
providing group services all right i'll
go into what all the heck that stuff
means in a few minutes but basically
zookeeper is a distributed consistent
data store favors consistency over
everything else
it is still highly available so it's
built to be a distributed system it's
not built to be a single standalone
whatever but it is built to favor
consistency it's also a high performance
system so believe it or not zookeeper
actually performs very very very well
under heavy load
and it is designed with performance in
mind so it's not slow the idea is that
you can really do a lot with zookeeper
and get results very very quickly so
that if you happen to have to put it on
a critical path somewhere it's not going
to drag you down too much
finally zookeeper provides strictly
ordered access for data so if you really
know when you're dealing with a piece of
data the state that that data is
actually in and you can trust that as
you access data you're ordering that you
are
modifying data and it's going to be
preserved by the system
so what do i mean by these things in
particular
highly available zookeeper tolerates a
minority of ensemble members being lost
and will still continue to function
minority means if you've got an ensemble
of n members you can tolerate n minus
one lead number two minus one loss
so if you have three nodes you can
tolerate one node going down if you have
five nodes you can tolerate two nodes
going down uh this is you know zookeeper
basics 101 but this is an important
point if you are running zookeeper we
recommend that you run an odd number of
nodes because you don't really get
anything from running an even number of
them if you run four nodes you can still
only tolerate the loss of a single
server before your zookeeper becomes
unavailable so generally speaking we
advise running three or five if you're
gonna run in production
do not if i is running a singleton node
even though
some of the storm documentation sort of
indicates maybe that's what you should
do i don't personally advise that unless
you don't care about your system being
unavailable if your zookeeper goes away
zookeepers high performance how does it
maintain the high performance all the
data is stored in memory
which means that it's been benchmarked
at around 50 000 operations a second
um
you know to be honest zookeeper
benchmarking is a question that we often
get on the mailing list
can i do this you know is this going to
perform well enough for me um and the
real answer with zookeeper benchmarking
is if you really really really care
about the numbers you have to benchmark
it yourself because it will depend on
your networks on your servers is it on
physical hosts this is on cloud vms is
it writing to its own disc because it
had its own transaction log separate
disk separate from other things or is it
sharing a disk with something else
that's chatty all of those different
things can affect how fast your
zookeeper actually is able to process
transactions so if you're you know
concerned with the zookeeper performance
for whatever reason hopefully you won't
be because i personally don't recommend
you know putting zuki or someplace where
you're going to be super sensitive to
performance um but you know maybe you
have a project and you really think this
is the right thing and you really care
what's the performance that i can get
out of this how many things can i
tolerate you know how many rights am i
going to get through how many reasons am
i going to get through that to market
yourself there's great tools online for
doing that if you go to the zookeeper
webpage you can find those
zookeeper is particularly tuned for read
performance so if you were doing a read
heavy right
light workload zookeeper is a good bet
that's because reads are always serviced
out of the node that you connect to your
client connects to they don't actually
have to do any kind of voting or
you know any kind of consensus to get
that value
finally strictly ordered access this is
really in many many ways the killer app
aspect of zookeeper and this is the
reason that you use it this is the
reason that it's out there in particular
we guarantee a few things guarantee
atomic writes if the right is the right
sailor going to completely succeed or
it's going to completely fail it is not
going to get into any kind of weird half
state
um
it is
we will do those atomic rights in the
order that you send them to the
zookeeper so your client says write
value x into node a then says right
value y to node a
you are going to see x then you're going
to see why that's the order that they
will be received no one's ever going to
see
y and then c x that will never ever
happen that's very important this is not
a guarantee that a lot of systems
provide you
um changes are also seen but in the
order that they occur so you're going to
send them and have them act in the order
that you sent them they'll be seen by
other people in the order that they
occurred and it's very reliable if it
acknowledges and right you're not going
to lose it uh are any of you guys
familiar with kyle kingsbury's jefferson
work
oh a few people okay very cool work
jefferson if you're familiar with carly
rae
the call me maybe anyway
okay a few more uh uh recognition so
he's done some really cool analysis of
the ways that these various distributed
systems fail when they fail in
production they all sort of hand wave in
their documentation oh you may or may
not lose data and he's done a lot of
work and showing exactly how you can
expect to lose data if you've got
really heavy loads going against your
nosql store and one of them fails and
he's done this with zookeeper and
pretty much nothing failed so we feel
very good about that uh proof out there
uh he's not tortured zookeeper nearly as
much as some people actually i think uh
facebook has done all more torturing
zookeeper than he has but it's a good
proof that zookeeper really does
live up to these guarantees because
that's what it is designed to do
so any questions about these basics
before i go on to some of the
additional basics okay
cluster interaction so what does super
actually look like right you've got an
ensemble you've got a leader and
followers all right
how does zookeeper work zookeeper starts
up um it goes through a voting algorithm
that i'm not going to describe because
i'm not sure i could if i wanted to
um whereby one node of the cluster is
elected to be the leader you will always
only have one leader
and that is very important for many of
the guarantees that zookeeper provides
so you create an ensemble
you get a forum you have a leader
you have a bunch of clients and they
connect to
nodes of the ensemble now the clients
can connect to the leader they cannot
connect to the leader you can configure
that um if you're not doing a huge heavy
load it doesn't really matter if you're
doing like a ton of writing you really
want your leader to be
optimally able to just concentrate on
writing so you probably don't want nodes
you don't want clients connected to your
leader
when clients connect to a node of the
zookeeper
cluster
the clients are creating a stateful
session that means that they are heart
meeting back to the node that they are
connected to at all times right you have
an open socket open to this cluster at
all times as long as you've got your
zookeeper client open and alive this is
important for a few things we'll get to
in a minute but this is just an
important thing to know right one of the
bottlenecks if you're running a gigantic
zookeeper you're running like a
magillian
clients is that the number of you know
sockets you can have open on a box will
limit the number of clients that connect
can connect into each individual server
so if you are planning for
hundreds of thousands of clients you
actually need to think a little bit if
you're not planning out for a hundred
thousand clients no big deal this is no
problem
so what happens when a
cluster member dies
so
if it dies we've still got enough to
have a quorum they can still talk to
each other no problem
but that node has gone away and clients
will see a disconnect event
at which point they will reconnect
themselves to another member of the
quorum and as long as they do that
within their session timeout their
sessions will still be alive and nothing
will change for them in terms of session
state so
this is
very useful because some of the basics
of zookeeper are session based and so
you want to be able to keep your session
alive you're actually alive even if a
note of the zookeeper cluster goes down
so this is the sort of basis of cluster
interaction
um
any questions about that
yes
if you have a single node zookeeper
cluster it's not running a leader in a
follower it's just running the
standalone singleton zoom looper so
there's no voting
to be done you either see it or you
don't and it's there
a um type you know
so why do we need a reader at all we can
have equal distribution like how you
know any clustering
why was the concept of a leader coming
up first of all okay so why do we have a
leader in zookeeper
the leader is required because the
leader is a core part of the zookeeper
zookeeper atomic broadcast algorithm
that is a consensus algorithm so axos is
the classic consensus algorithm that you
may have learned in school
notoriously notoriously difficult to
understand and implement
zookeeper atomic broadcast also ps
notoriously difficult to understand and
implement but at least has been
implemented correctly because the people
that invented it
did it inside of this system
but
algorithm is also used by other sql
databases like
i don't have any concept of so
i i i we can definitely discuss that
offline but
zookeeper's algorithm is a leader-based
algorithm you have to have a leader for
it to work if zookeeper the zookeeper
atomic broadcast protocol relies on the
leader to provide certain guarantees
around that consistency and ordering so
without that it will not work
if they had this was the initial concept
i'm not sure why they are not changing
it so that's a question for probably the
apaches
sure
yes
so you said that the session is still
intact does that mean that the session
is being replicated among the cluster as
well
or is it i can't imagine it's sort of
fine
it i think it is
uh that session events all go through
the leader
yeah sorry question so the question is
because you know the session stays alive
how does it stay alive and the answer is
that all session events also go through
the leader so i do believe that sessions
are stored not just on the word that
you're attached to and not just in the
client but also in the other nodes of
the cluster so you can reconnect to
another place and re-establish oh okay
i'm not sure what a session event is in
that case because a read is not a
session event obviously no a session is
like literally the state of the client
being connected to a server that is like
the session the
open socket as it were
for example if the
node on the client
so the client though can theoretically
have a disconnect event obviously in the
middle of a reach
not in the middle of a read because of
the way that i mean there's not i
was like hey if someone blows up my
server someone blows up your server the
bill of you processing a read yes
you could have a session disconnect
should disconnect an event but you would
you would see the read event as sort of
a singleton event and then you would get
the results of that or you get a
disconnect
so if the leader goes away the remaining
cluster will re-elect a new leader and
so the cluster itself will be
unavailable while selecting a new leader
meaning it won't respond to requests but
once the leader is reelected the cluster
will continue to
process requests and i can't remember if
you see an event if the client scene and
then when that happens they probably do
but i don't remember on the top of my
head so does that mean the session data
will go away if the leader dies in
between the session will not go right
now everything is replicated everywhere
so you really do not lose
it it's very difficult to lose anything
from this design because everything is
everywhere to some degree of statements
some degree of sort of time lag
yes
any kind of thing that talks to a
zookeeper so we we provide a actual
um
protocol
um zookeeper we implement it in java and
c natively um and so anything
implemented on top of those that
implements the zookeeper protocol that
can actually talk to a zookeeper
ensemble is a zookeeper client but the
end goal isn't necessarily
able to talk to something else that's
also connected yeah the end goal could
be to talk to something else right so
this client
so this client contains logic to talk to
the zookeeper but it actually may be
using the zookeeper so that they can
look up something else something inside
the zookeeper and find another system
yeah
yes
on how much capacity so certainly
yes there's a like realistic limit as to
how much you can send over the network
um we recommend
data wise if you're actually storing
data so actually that brings me nicely
into the zookeeper data structure suzuki
or data structure tree of nodes root is
actually forward slash so forgive me i
did not put proper root in here if you
imagine you have node a a can have
children it can also have data so those
things that look sort of like pieces of
paper that's data
um so nodes can have children they can
have data they can have both
um
and
so
you can store data in the zookeeper and
you you know you should you probably
will
the goal though is not to store a lot of
data in the zookeeper you don't want to
have huge nodes
because that's going to cause you
performance problems right zookeeper is
all stored in memory and it is java so
for those of you who are not jvm experts
maybe you all are if you're a jboxer you
know what i mean when i say you don't
want this thing garbage collecting
because you're going to start to see a
lot of problems
and in particular we just recommend that
nodes there's actually a limit set on
the zookeepers for the size of notes and
you have to override that default if you
want to go any bigger i think the limit
is 1k maybe 10k something like that
is it one mag now all right i loaded it
way much when i was uh working with
zookeeper last and so i recommend much
less than one bank i think one meg is a
dangerous size of data to put in a
zookeeper particularly when you're
talking about something that's going to
be living in memory
so those are some of the practical
limitations of getting data to and from
the zookeeper you don't really just want
to stick a ton of data in there that
more data is going to know the longer
it's going to take to process yeah is
the depth of the hierarchy of the data
structure also a problem if you have too
many oh the typical hierarchy i mean
not not you not really the nodes
themselves are not that big so if you
have a ton and a ton of times notes at
some point it will become a problem i
forget the exact measured size of nodes
at this point um we've done the analysis
i think we've shrunk it a little bit
recently but the nodes themselves are
not that big so
the depth of the hierarchy is not that
big a deal what can become
you know in its java system so
if you create a bunch of things and then
delete them and create a bunch of
totally different things if that data
gets really big and you start to get
into full garbage collection mode in
your zookeeper you're going to kind of
hit some pain because sockets don't
really work well under full gc and java
so
that's going to even mind
but you know most part people don't have
too much problems with that
yes
is everything completely stored in the
heap or other options
no everything is stored in memory yeah
there is no right now we have no
no roadmap for storing any zookeeper
data anywhere other than in memory um
who knows what facebook is doing but
besides that nobody i know is working on
that yeah system has moved from heap to
map implementation since the new version
of java so it is accessible easily it is
in memory but it's not the java keyboard
yeah
yeah i think that's that's a reasonable
question it's accessible but it's not a
dummy so you don't have to worry about
the garbage collector looking over it um
you know right now
most people don't if you use zookeeper
for the like 99.9 most common use cases
you're not going to have any of these
issues so it's really more problem if
you start using it for really strange
things
yes i think all these questions
is not meant to be used as a data store
do you think we're not meant to use
yes exactly zookeeper is really not
meant to be a data store for large
amounts of data right it's just not
that's not what it is it's a
coordination service it's a distributed
locking service it's not really a data
store
so here's the data structure one thing
you'll note about this data structure is
that we have one node that's sort of
shaded differently and has a client
connected to it
this is one of the key
aspects of zookeeper that you will use
if you use it which is ephemeral nodes
those are session based nodes
that means that when the client goes
away the node goes away
that's super super useful if you're
using zookeeper for example to determine
who is alive and available in your
cluster so you can sort of manage
sending jobs to them if those folks are
advertising themselves in zookeeper by
creating ephemeral nodes the minute they
die and their note goes away you don't
have to worry about pinging them or
cleaning up you can say okay they can't
see the zookeeper i'm going to consider
them dead
and i can continue you know sending my
tasks to the remaining live notes
um another feature that i will just
quickly point out is also that we have
sequential nodes this is e001
you can have you know ever increasing
sequence numbers on nodes which is
useful for unique naming and a few other
things
so notice how data children are both
ephemeral is associated with the session
that created them so remember as i was
saying clients if they are attached to a
zookeeper member that fails their
session will still remain alive if they
reconnect to another member that's
useful when you've got a femoral node's
written right that means that those
nodes will not go away and you won't
have to recreate them
as long as your session doesn't actually
get disconnected
so the second major sort of basic
feature of zookeeper is watches
water watches so watches are
a way for you to be notified when some
piece of state changes in zookeeper um
here's how it looks so you've got
you want to put a watch on some data for
a node so get data from my node foo true
indicates i'm sending a watch
and then it returns the data that
happens to be a foo right now which is
my data
now if another client goes in and says
set the data in food to be bar
right
then once that
that once that set has been acknowledged
the notification goes to the client that
put the watch that says hey the data in
node foo has changed you were getting a
watch on this event that you registered
that is all you know is that something
has changed you do not know what changed
you do not know how many times it
changed you just know the first time
that it changed you had been notified
so now if you want to see what was the
change you call git data again in this
case we're resetting the watch with that
true and now i'm saying okay the data
changed tomorrow
watches are tricky to think about
because they are one-time notifications
they are not events it's not like you
can use a watch to say every time
somebody does x y or z tell me tell me
tell me tell me i want to see every
single change that happened here that's
not the point of watches watchers are
more about observing a stage change and
less about having a perfect event stream
coming to you
they're ordered with respect to other
events watches and asynchronous replies
so you'll see
a watch event for a node that's watching
before you see the new data
corresponding to that node so you could
not possibly read data from a node and
get back the new data before you
actually saw the watch notification to
your client
um and the order of the watch event
corresponds to the order of updates is
seen by the zookeeper
and again one time notification it must
be reset so the point of this is not so
that you see every single change to a
node but rather that you know when a
node changes so that you can go and see
what change what this new state is maybe
the new state is the old tick because it
changed and then it went back to what it
was in the time between when you got the
notification and when you acted on it
that's okay that's all we guarantee here
any quick questions about watches
great
so basic expiration api create delete
set data
you can take a lot of the everything in
zookeeper has apples uh so that's kind
of nice except that the apples aren't
recursive so if you have a parent node
with some apples on it you create a
child load of that parent it's not going
to have the parents
apples that's really annoying actually
it's really really annoying if you
happen to care about that in production
you have to write a client that will
always respect parents apples and
propagate them to children
it's unfortunate but that happens but
these are the creation api
the get slash watch api so these calls
will give you some sort of state and you
can use them to set watches
um note that pretty much all of these
can be run either synchronously or
asynchronously so if you write it
synchronously you will wait for the
results to come back from the zookeeper
uh if you run the asynchronous city life
should pass the future and that will be
sort of triggered actually i'm going to
be past the future in uh java it'll
put it on the event queue anyway so
you'll actually see it as event so you
can do it more throughput if you run it
asynchronously
so if you really really care about
throughput to the zookeeper you use the
async calls versus the same calls
finally we have a couple more less basic
things in the api new in 3.4 we have
multi which is actually pretty cool you
can train chain together a group of
operations send them to the zookeeper
they will either all succeed or all fail
together as a group you will not get
sort of partial success or failure this
is
useful if you want to do certain
operations
you know it's a it's pretty nice i
recommend you checking it out if you
have anything you think would be good
with that
and then there's sync
so what does sync do sync
helps the zookeeper make sure that it's
actually
uh in line with the latest update to a
node before you read it um so one thing
about zookeeper is again because it has
that quorum so you have a leader and
followers if your follower that your
client is connected to it's a little bit
behind the leader it can only get so far
behind the leader before it will be cut
off but it can get a little bit behind
the leader and that means that it may
not have seen the latest update to a
particular node if you really must have
seen the latest update before you read
something you use the sync command to
pull that data into that follower
and make sure and that will slow down
your reads that it will make sure that
you're seeing updated data
yeah
yes so it guarantees it guarantees
consistency insofar as you're ever going
to see
uh you know you're never going to see
rights out of order you're never going
to be able to read something that hasn't
been acknowledged by everyone but you
can get one node can get behind to a
small delta from other nodes so that is
that is the one thing there is an
eventual consistency element there
that's what the sync command is for it
actually lets you force a more real
consistency there
yeah
since everything is consistent and
persistent
i'm just trying to understand why do we
need watch because every time
uh it sends uh
what is
this
so
so why do you need watches
i'm not sure i understand everything is
positioned
everything is like too faced
but the watches are just notifying
somebody else that's interested in
knowing that data changed
that's all it is so you don't have to
pull so imagine that you are
implementing config dynamic
configuration in zookeeper which is a
common use case right you want to know
when the config change but you don't
want to have to if you put it in a
database or in a file system you'd have
to be polling and see did the file
change or did this flag get written or
whatever okay now i'm going to reread
the config and see what it changed
zookeeper will just tell you you set the
watch and say tell me when this change
okay something changed i'm going to
reread my config
so
that's that's the point of watches
stop watching
all right
so moving on quickly just common uses i
think common uses basically fall into
two major categories service management
and distributed logging um there's a lot
of different names for service
management a lot of different words but
i think that pretty much most of the
things that people really use this for
service management
um that includes coordination so storm
all of you guys are familiar with storm
zookeeper is the source of communication
between nimbus and the supervisors what
does that mean that means you've got the
stateless nimbus that is sort of the
master or whatever
um that can come up wherever uh and
you've got these supervisors that come
and go and are you know maybe you add
more maybe you take more or
protocol less that the numbers and the
supervisors could find each other and
sort of know where each other are and
say oh okay well we know that this guy's
there and it's live and healthy yeah
uh you know they just
took the easy way out and said you know
what instead of trying to write our own
protocol to find each other and make
sure everyone's alive make sure
everyone's kicking and working well
we're just going to use zookeeper
they're going to write stuff into
zookeeper nimbus is going to look into
zookeeper to find the supervisors and
then it will connect to supervisors and
send them work but we don't actually
need to write a protocol for finding
each other
this is just a hugely common use case
for zookeeper it's a very good one
uh discovery as i mentioned before right
if you're running a big solar
infrastructure this is one of the
biggest things i've done with zookeeper
is
a really giant discovery server
you can use dns for this but it's kind
of a pain you can use zookeeper and it
works quite well you want to find
services that are doing job products
so you encode that job as a path in
zookeeper and every server that comes up
running that service is going to
register under that path and maybe they
say things like i'm running version 4 of
the protocol i'm running version 5 of
the protocol whatever i have you know 10
clients connected i have 100 clients
connected you can use all of that
information as much as you want to
to
actually sort of encode where your
services are running and let clients use
the zookeeper to find the services that
they want to connect to um this is a
first class you know use case for
zookeeper very easy
very well implemented
configuration as i just mentioned
reading things from nodes
watch the nodes or config changes very
very simple straightforward and robust
if you want to do dynamic configuration
up to dynamic configuration has some
risks to it but if you want to do it
zookeeper is a great way to do it
and finally locking if you are doing
distributed locking and you are not
using zookeeper you are crazy
this is i don't know what else is out
there that
does truly like
safe distributed locking if you actually
really want safe and accurate
distributed locks i think zookeeper is
the way to do it personally um what does
that mean that means you're implementing
barriers and latches for whatever reason
you've got a bunch of processes out
there running you want to make sure all
of them have completed something before
they move forward
right use zookeeper
uh you want to use a shared lock sorry
this is weird and out of order but you
have a shared lock so you have a couple
of processes that might be
uh
pulling data from a queue that's
destructive right so you can only have
one process actually pulling data from
that queue but you want to have a hot
backup available in case the main
process goes down you can use a shared
block or sort of a leader election style
algorithm to implement that
also if you want to do any kind of too
faced commit guarantee that a majority
of my followers have seen a piece of
data being written before i actually
commit that data to disk and i say okay
i believe this is solid right that's
almost the fundamental of the zookeeper
algorithm itself is
sort of a two case commit type thing and
this is just exposing that so you can
actually use it yourselves for whatever
you need to do with them
so those are the major
again high level i said this is for
beginners these are the major high-level
use cases there are recipes out there
that implement all of those things
because this is the scary part of
zookeeper
my kitten he's so scared
now look for the cat that's right
this is the client's client-side estate
machine of zookeeper um maybe this
doesn't look that bad to you i can
promise you as an implementer this is
kind of a gigantic painting to get
correct and actually
parse and operate on correctly there's a
lot of different states that can happen
and you have to parse them correctly and
they're coming in on a separate channel
from other operations you have to know
oh you're in a session expired state so
i have to close my connection and
reconnect to the zookeeper i'm in a
connection lost state so i'm just
waiting to be reconnected and hopefully
i will reconnect properly oh my auth
failed i have to completely close clean
up my connection and reconnect this is
all kind of
difficult to deal with
and i personally recommend not having to
deal with this if you at all possibly
can in fact i recommend saying nope nope
nope
nope to all of that because
it's really very painful
and instead using one of the best in
class clients if you're in java as many
of you who are in the store probably are
possibly are curator is a pretty good
one that curator is what storm uses
that's a client out of netflix it also
implements a ton of those recipes those
sort of common use cases so if you have
one of those common use cases you use
java curator is a pretty well supported
library pretty easy to use and you won't
have to think quite as much about it
kazoo is a python first class zookeeper
library they actually implemented the
protocol it's pretty awesome i know the
guy who wrote it and he is pretty
awesome
so i would definitely use that if i were
using python zookeeper
twitter commons also has a few utilities
for zookeeper namely discovery but a few
other things so if you happen to be
using twitter comments you've already
got zoom keeper um almost all the big
sort of soa framework web framework
systems in java now have somebody that's
done a zookeeper binding client for them
somewhere right i think drop wizard has
a spring play probably has one so if
you're in that solo world if you're in
that web services world where you're
interested in discovery
you can probably find someone having has
written that code for you out there and
i recommend go ahead and use it it's
probably fine
yeah
yeah zookeeper itself
provides a c client
you know not the zookeeper's science lab
yeah it's not amazing it's not amazing
but it is unfortunately the best i know
i don't know that anyone else has
written ac client uh this i mean the c
client in the zookeeper library is at
least pretty heavily tested
so um there's that
and we made it work for c plus plus ish
but i know it's not amazing if you want
to compile it a mac os x doesn't work
right now it's really annoying
um
in the
branches are working on so
but you know it is definitely out there
available and heavily the c client is
heavily used by a number of people in
fact the multi the new multi api uh was
created by someone who really heavily
uses the seat client so it's out there
it's in quite active use
so
finally i leave you to
the advice with zookeeper which is that
you should be aware when you're running
it it's a solid system it's very well
written
but
it does in some ways own your
availability if you use it as
a key part of your stack right so
if you are relying on zookeeper being
available for you to be able to find
services to connect to and do any work
or if you're relying on zookeeper event
to be available for you to be able to
become the leader and pull from this
pipeline or if you're relying on
zookeeper to be available to you know
hand work off to task workers
if zookeeper is down you're done
now
you can architecture on this to some
extent you can just sort of accept that
this is a key part of my system but i'm
going to try to limit its use to only
the really really vulnerable and
important parts and keep it there
um zookeeper actually is pretty
operationally sound we don't see a lot
of people having huge operational
problems oh my god my zookeeper blew up
and i lost my whole two days of whatever
right it's that's not a very common
thing but
if you're going to run a zookeeper
cluster in production you should just
simply be aware that it is an important
piece of
infrastructure for you plug your
learning around it read about the best
practices of using it put monitoring on
it you want to know if it's going to be
in distress because it will cause you
some pain if it does
um
the other thing i will note that i
didn't forget to note in this talk is
that storm is using zookeeper very
lightly so if you've got a zookeeper
cluster that's only running for storm
you can use that zookeeper cluster for
other things the nice thing about
zookeeper is that especially in most of
its open source uses it's not used very
very very heavily it's necessary but
it's not like they're putting every
single piece of state in it and i have
read a number of places online where
people have said i just use the same
zookeeper cluster for my storm and my
kafka and my hbase and it's fine and i
can't promise you that that will be fine
but i can tell you that you know there
are people out there doing it it's a
fine piece to have [ __ ] as shared
infrastructure as long as you have
people paying attention to it monitoring
it and making sure it continues to be
healthy because misbehaving clients can
cause problems for everyone else yeah
also just one more thing
people have a pretty good ch looking
technique so you can see it throughout
every other time
yes yes they have a good chrome
technique that i've never personally
used but yet that is built in so that
you don't have to worry about what my
group node is i'm using it for this
project that project or the other
project i'm just automatically in the
right place
so
that is all from me
um
thank you
somebody help me with
somebody's whose slides i found on the
watch slide so this guy's ea i don't
know him but he was very helpful thanks
to him again tweet me if you have
questions that's my email if you want to
get in touch with me here's some links
to some of the clients you can google
them yourself but i put everything in
the slides um and
right the wrong way is hiring if you
happen to be looking for something very
different um we're actually a very cool
place for them i'm happy to talk about
that but
more questions
i know this is a storm uh
uh beat up but can you just quickly
in like five minutes as possible explain
how zip keeper is used in hybrid phase
because that is
i am not a super expert at how to use
businesses i know that at least one of
its uses
is for
task assignment
um so you know i know all these nodes
are available i'm going to use i'm
assigning my tasks and i'm not an expert
on having to reread it so if somebody
else knows
service management service management
stuff
tracker
track of you know assignment tests
but i think
it's just
kind of like managing to distribute the
fastest thing and knowing where it is
yeah so my specific question was i
didn't want to get into detail but maybe
if you can't answer it quickly otherwise
you can take this offline but
you've got the hdfs so you've got a
bunch of regions that are created on
various nodes and it's distributed now
hps is acting as a client that is using
zookeeper to see where the venues are
located and that's the master and not
the master but the leader and the slaves
that you talk about
so if one of those fails in the region
servers
like you know the location i can't get
to that i just was wondering how the
failure like you talked about a
toothpaste current
okay
where you're trying to keep does it use
toothpaste or does it because there is
i'm sorry i could not answer that
question i'm sure i could find the
answer for you but i do not know the
answer though
about how that works yes um is it fair
to say that the future efforts and
development in super would be targeted
to accommodate the apache family of big
data software uh is it fair to say that
they're targeted to accommodate the
apache family of software
sort of i mean honestly like zookeeper
is
suzuki is one of the very few products
out there that has nobody whose
full-time job as far as i know is to
support the open source version of
zookeeper um so it's a project that
moves slowly
probably it also moves slowly because it
has to be
reasonably solid before it goes into
those out there before we put our stamp
of approval on them because we don't
want people using this as a system that
they really really heavily rely on and
then all of a sudden zookeeper is losing
data on you that's really you know
that's not our our point um
a number of the committers do work
on for like cloudera um or hortonworks
so they are you know out there in the
hadoop community thinking about how
hbase or whatever you know hdfs aj needs
to be using zookeeper but actually most
of the future development on zookeeper
has been
of two types it's been academic so three
five is actually going to have
recommend reconfiguration of the
zookeeper cluster so you will not have
to
actually take the cluster down to
reconfigure it that's a hugely complex
like literally published academic papers
worth of complexity
so
that's sort of one-sided development
actually comes out of research efforts
from various companies that was actually
out of yahoo but out of various
companies and then the other side
actually comes from large companies like
facebook and sierra places like that
even goldman sachs when i was there that
are using zookeeper in various sort of
enterprise or really really large scale
ways that it doesn't quite work as well
with right now so facebook has a number
of patches out there that we're working
through to increase the ability to
handle connections or have many many
observer nodes or
you know
process certain data faster and really
even improve the throughput of zookeeper
because they're just putting a ton of
stuff through zookeeper so those are
actually the biggest changes to
zookeeper are actually coming more from
new clients using it new distributed
systems being built and enterprise and
academic efforts really actually it's
fairly stable in the hadoop
family
but in the apache family i mean like
zakaku definitely pushes certain things
in sometimes so that client also
has caused a few changes in zookeepers
since it's been
created fair to say it's guaranteed that
you work with most of the apology stuff
at minimum yeah i mean it will
definitely work with the apache stuff i
mean we you know we certainly i'm sure
that uh all of the like hadoop things
are certifying themselves against a
version of zookeeper so they say they
know that they run taylor but we don't
do a lot of backward breaking changes in
zookeepers so you don't have a lot to
worry about there with respect to the
reconfiguration apis that you mentioned
i don't know anyone that is
definitely using it in production now
i would be scared to put my production
personally yes i would leave it in stage
for a very long time
yeah
any company
commercializing zookeeper now
now like i said we can't even get anyone
to be working on the open source project
full-time we're all like very very
part-time committers so um it's just too
what what are we gonna do you know what
are you gonna sell this for right this
that's actually one of the nice things
about zookeeper it works pretty freaking
well there's not really a lot of need to
you know put extra special bells and
whistles and shine on it
because you know what it does right now
is good enough for almost everyone
yeah
i'm not sure
um you only have one leader yes so you
always only have one leader
so
all rights go to the leader
so the leader is responsible for doing
the implementing the zookeeper algorithm
and that algorithm basically at a very
very high level
works so
if you have a right wherever it is it
goes to the leader it's forwarded to the
leader
the leader then subproposes it
to all of the followers and they vote on
whether they will accept that proposal
or not meaning that they vote to say i
see this it you know matches my belief
of the sequence of events
i can write this to this family
acknowledge it so they will vote as long
as
the point at which a majority of the
followers vote to say yes this is good
then the leader sends a commit message
and everybody commits that they
acknowledge it to the leader and then
the leader sends that acknowledgement
back to the client
so there's always only one leader there
can only be one is there ever two
leaders you could get out of sync and
you would not have any of the guarantees
the zookeeper has
when the leader goes away would they go
into a voting algorithm and all the
nodes of the zookeeper that are still
available will vote to elect a new
leader
right
so you said in the config you set up
what all the nodes are right now you
have to configure exactly the location
of all of the nodes in the cluster
right and each each node has the config
in it but you don't say which node is
going to be the later right and
whichever node you know gets elected
when you first start up is the later
okay
yeah so i'm fairly new to configuring
first in the config file the specified 2
8 8 8 and 3 888 are those used i guess
for internal
communications between zookeeper nodes
yeah the ports there's a there's a few
different ports that are open there's
yeah there's a voting port there's a
um and then there's like the actual
communication and then there's like
admin ports so i don't remember what
what confirm
i
i spent a lot of time on the internet uh
looking for things it seemed to say that
i need to drop into the
command line interface in order to
create like a root node you may need to
for octa yes okay so okay
if you're getting them known exceptions
it means
often what it means is that it's trying
to create a path and one of the nodes in
that path perhaps the root does not
exist um that has to be created you know
at some point otherwise you'll get a
note exists exception it already exists
um so i'm guessing then to start popping
off maybe you have to actually create
its route
okay cool yeah so i have a question uh
yes there's a sort of rolling upgrade
that we recommend doing that will
minimize your downtime um you'll have
you should sort of google zookeeper
rolling upgrade and it's documented
somewhere but basically the
recommendation is
sort of node by node you upgrade it they
won't be able to connect back into the
cluster um and so you'll you'll swap
from having a majority in the old
version to a majority of the new version
and your clients will see downtime and
they will see their sessions get
disconnected they'll have to reconnect
but other than that it should be fairly
seamless to your clients it's actually a
very small amount of down time
just make sure your leader is the last
one to be updated yeah
yes
the class
when the leader goes
i don't know that i don't think sessions
are broken when that happens i think the
clients actually get a disconnected
exception but when the new leader is
elected they should their session should
still be alive as long as they are alive
i'm just trying to understand from
client perspective is to keep her become
a single point of failure and we have to
deal with it somehow our client is smart
clients should be smart enough to
reconnect as long as your keyboard is
still alive so like i said like i showed
in that diagram earlier if the node that
you're connected to goes away the
clients that exist up there are written
in such a way that they will reconnect
to another node of the zookeeper
and if the leader goes away but you are
connected to another node zookeeper will
elect a new leader and then you'll be
fine and uh how long does the process
actually take because each base for
example take like a long time few
minutes to select
so i don't know what's going on there
i'm very interested to hear more details
about the leader election should be
pretty
fast on the network
i'm sure it depends on the network and
hard drive but it should not take it
shouldn't take minutes it should take
maybe seconds
if that
is the encryption available for
communication among
these products
among the zookeepers i don't know we do
support ssl to the zookeeper
a lot of clients yes that's like a new
feature of 3-4
um but i don't know about actually
within the zookeepers themselves
yeah
yeah
i don't yeah i i don't remember whether
that actually i think it's just clients
too deeper i don't know that it's within
intro zookeeper as it were
yeah
just a quick question have you
tried
uh
yes um and that's very much
uh i have i have done a lot of work
actually with zookeeper across data
centers and particularly across global
data centers and
yes but that's like a whole other time
but yes i mean you have to check the
latency it is it is an important thing
yeah
about how old is zookeeper as an open
source project and what's uh what's next
on the roadmap
how old is it that's a good question
um seven years
maybe
eight years what year is it
2006 is when i think it came out yeah
so that would make it seven seven seven
eight years something like that um what
is next on the right half wall works
really very hard trying to get 3.4.6 at
3.5 out the door it's taking a very long
time 3.5 has dynamic reconfig this is
its major new cool feature um there's
also a few other like interesting sort
of performance optimization things
um in three five yeah
sorry and uh so that's that's what i
know
that those are sort of the major things
on the road right now we've got a lot a
big ticket backlog
you know this is a project where it
takes a long time to to modify so
just as a follow-up to that if people
are interested in diving in and helping
out yeah what are emojis
if you're interested in diving and
helping out we mark tickets as newbie so
look at the newbie tickets um we try
very hard to pay attention when people
especially when new people provide
patches so i recommend looking at the
newbie tickets i recommend joining all
the mailing lists and reading a lot and
becoming as much as you can an expert
and actually running zookeeper yourself
because
really that is the
that's the most important thing is that
you you are a person that truly
understands the system
zookeeper ensembles across data centers
um so the leaders
and the followers would be in different
data centers that moved to the continent
to the us
but also across um to asia and um
more than two data centers
three days yeah you have to do three
data centers so if you care about losing
a data center you have to have some
people running at three data centers
that's the same it's the same sort of
logic as if you care about you know
losing nodes you really want an odd
number of nodes if you want to lose two
you have to have five if you want to
lose a single data center you have to
have three data centers
it sort of goes the same way unless you
have that
make a lot of people's lives easier
hopefully
all right um i am it's been an hour and
i'm tired and i think you guys are all
tired so i'll be here for a few more
minutes thank you so much for coming